[Musique]
je suis madame rickmounie christiane
j'ai 61 ans et je suis femme il
accueille depuis 12 ans
mon mari a été malade pendant un an
suite à sa maladie une très longue
amputation de la jambe hospitalisation à
domicile c'était vraiment réduit
attribué à supporter pour mes enfants et
moi il est on est arrivés les
finalisations domicile nous a aidés qui
dit qui est à la maison c'était presque
tout ce qui est admis par la suite j'ai
soigné ma mère et c'est après ça j'ai
décidé d'être famille d'accueil patients
parce que avec ses personnages et il
faut être attentif car le coup
de temps en temps ils nous appellent
c'est pour rien ça y est pour vous voir
il fallait le banc de temps en temps
tout ce qui était à s'arrêter un peu
mieux non la mer bah oui
[Musique]
je viens c'est trop loin je reçois les
personnes âgées chez moi mais ils sont
libres ils peuvent faire parce qu'il
remet du moins s'ils ont besoin de
sentir qu'ils sont pas enfermés chez
nous c'est pas une prison il peut
recevoir de la famille des amis c'est
comme s'il vivait à vêtements ce
monsieur est chez moi ça fait déjà 10 10
ans
[Musique]